etonnant non c'est une émission de radio
funny cela s'appelle les chroniques de
la haine ordinaire ce matin lac qui
était le matin du septième jour dieu ne
se sentait pas très bien
il faut dire que les six premiers jours
il n'avait pas ménagé sa peine
créant coup sur coup la lumière la terre
les maires l'homme les animaux
le ciel bleu les étoiles jaunes enfin
tout ce [ __ ] de bordel de dieu qui
nous entoure et sans lequel nous
n'aurions jamais pu connaître l'arthrite
du genou et la bombe à neutrons et donc
le septième jour dieu se sentit mou et
sans fut consultez-le interne de garde à
l'hôtel dieu
comment allez-vous mon dieu sans qu'ils
docteur et dieu dit bof comme un lundi
c'est fâcheux dit le docteur on est
dimanche mais que ressentez-vous
précisément mon dieu est dieu dit c'est
difficile à dire j'ai l'impression
d'être creux et sans contours voyez
comme comme qui dirait ballonné mais
sans la baudruche autour du rien j'ai
l'impression de ne pas être là et de ne
pas être ailleurs non plus et pour être
clair docteur je crois que je crois que
je n'existe pas et dans ma situation
vous comprendrez que c'est extrêmement
pénible rassurez vous ce n'est qu'une
sensation affirma le docteur qui était
plus pieux qu'une cuisse de grenouille
intégristes je vais tout de même vous
examinez 10 33 et dieu dit on ne donne
pas d'ordre à dieu on le prix
excusez moi je vous prie de dire 33 10
le docteur et dieu 10 33 33 33 bien
maintenant faite à je vous prie de faire
à et dieu dix à vingt dieux s'exclama le
docteur qui voyait grand et dieu très
inquiète dit et aux amis a et bien mon
dieu c'est tout à fait incroyable
vous avez la gorge si sombre que je n'y
vois rien et dieu dit c'est normal les
voies du seigneur sont impénétrables
mais non c'est moi ce que je veux dire
mais mon dieu vous n'avez pas de moi
profond et sans son moi profond personne
ne peut vivre repris le docteur tiens
quand je vous disais que j'existais pas
c'est pas des conneries dit dieu c'est
égal on est bien peu de chose constaté
le docteur on est même rien du tout oui
dit dieu ni moi ni vous puisque sans moi
sans moi pour vous créez vous l'avez
dans le néant
au nom de dieu dit le docteur je vous en
prie et dis dieu bon il combien vous
dois-je docteur proches c'est pas moins
de dix mois ce que vous voulez donnez
nous aujourd'hui notre pain quotidien
comme d'habitude comme d'habitude et
deux baguettes bien cuites pour le dr
freud des dieux
quant au mois de mars
je le dis sans aucune arrière pensée
politique cela m'étonnerait qu'ils pas
ce qu'ils veulent c'est non non
[Musique]